hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're gonna be hopping out
monster on a world again and we're gonna
be talking about the best gathering set
for farming resources resources include
insects nuts seeds all that type of
stuff like plants and herbs and bone
piles and all that stuff most of the
stuff we're gonna be needing obviously
in the game depending on what type of
weapon you have you might need a lot of
flame herbs and stuff like that so
you're going to need these a lot
especially no berries toward the later
end of the game so let's get right into
this build real quick so for the gear I
have the chainmail head gear be you can
also use bone as well for the head gear
if you want some smaller monster parts
as well it's completely entirely up to
you we're gonna go into a bit of what
these mean but going up next we have the
Ratheon male a as the chest piece the
hunter's coil B as like the belt buckle
area and pookay Greaves a for the pants
I couldn't find good enough arms to do
this with to fit this build overdoing
the skills and it being pointless for
example I did find some gloves that
ended up giving me two levels in the
botanist perk but that would ended that
would end up giving me six and overdoing
my limit cuz the limit is four thus
making it entirely useless this is the
build that I had with the materials I
was given but to go over what they do
chain the OB is gonna give you master
gatherer which allows you to gather
items more quickly instead of sitting
there and carving at it away you'll grab
it really quickly and just book off to
the next one the bone helmet which is
the another option besides the chain no
helmet will give you entomologist which
decreases the chance of small monster
bodies disappearing so you can gather
more of their scales hides and stuff
like that Ratheon male and pookay pants
will give you botanist to each making a
botanist level four which will allow you
to gain one more herb fruit seed nut
insect or mushroom for gather and then
the hunters coil will give you the
master gatherer which like we said it
helps you gather more items quickly this
is why I recommended using the bone
because the highest thing you can go on
for master gatherer is one and having
the chainmail on top and the hunters
coil is gonna give you two thus giving
thus giving you too much more than you
need and then it's kind of redundant so
that's why I do recommend using the bone
helmet just to get those small monster
bodies just in case you need them for
the recommended decorations I would just
strictly go with geology and specimen
geology increases the number of times
you can use a gathering point and
specimen decreases the chance of small
survive these disappearing which is the
exact same as the entomologist which is
on the bone helmet thus giving you an
extra level making it even better for
the charms you can either use the
geology charm for more levels in the
geologists skill which we just talked
about the insect charm for more
entomology skills whatever one fits your
need or you can go with the Geo Mansi
charm which is the one I used which
gives you forwarders luck which gives
you more of a chance to find rare
gathering points and also marks those
points on your wildlife map to come back
later this build is gonna be giving you
tons of resources so you don't have to
waste time continuously collecting and
going back to the base just to collect
the things you need you're gonna be
doing this in minutes as opposed to
where it would be taking you 10 to 20
minutes to maybe get the things that you
need to prep for a fight especially if
you're going to need no berries I know
later in the game there's gonna be some
other dragons that need no berry
especially if you want to farm them
you're gonna be needing some no berries
if you do want to farm their gear and
obviously you can just get the no
berries from the map that they're in but
that might not be enough for you maybe
you're not as good or maybe you're just
like me and just absolutely trash and
you lose and you use a lot of no berries
within an entire fight so coming
prepared with lots of them on a surplus
is always nice and that's gonna be the
end of the video guys hope you guys did
enjoy this really quick build with the
hunting and gathering if you guys have
any other ideas for builds you want me
to try and come up with I'll be glad to
make those as well like the video if you
did enjoy it really does help me out
subscribe if you're new I got a bunch of
solo guides at monster Honor with more
coming on the way or as well as other
guides and tutorials that for Monster
Hunter as well my two most recent months
around her videos are going to be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guys hope you have a great
rest errday and peace out